تقنيه الحبوب القابله للهضم تستخدم تستخدم
المجالات المغنيطسيه لتتبع الحركه عبر
الجهاز الهضمي بدقه اعلى هذه التقنيه
تعتبر اسهل بكثير مقارنه بالجراحه فهي
تسهل تشخيص وعلاج اضطرابات الحركه المعويه
المعديه هذه الحبه الذكيه القابله للهضم
يتم تعقب حركتها خلال جهاز الهضمي والتي
تتصل عبر هاتف ذكي باستخدام تقنيه
البلوتوث ويامل الاطباء والباحثون ان تحمل
هذه التكنولوجيا الجديده تشخيصا لامراض
اكثر خاصه الايضيه والنفسيه وحتى العصبيه
منها
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات